hey I'm Issa Rae and I am playing April
in the movie little I am Regina ha and I
play big Jordan and I am our st. Martin
and I play a little Jordan in the movie
little today we're gonna be answering
some questions giving a little advice to
women old and old and young alike that's
very easy if you're super young
they're super oh no he's now some of
them do you want to pull first yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you stay true to who you are when
there's not much of your identity
represented on screen for me it was
surrounding myself with people who who
look like me and then making that kind
of work making the representation I
wanted to see on the screen you know I
just things that resonated with like
I've always been a little unique so you
know I find maybe they're pieces of
people that remind me of myself in one
character or another it may not be like
a full representation in one person but
I have a tendency to you know notice and
enjoy that which is similar to me on
whatever level exactly I think that's
why I'm doing right now is to inspire
young girls that look like me and to see
themselves represented on the big screen
to know how do you assert yourself
especially if you're one of the only
women in the room show them who you
really are like let your voice be heard
of course tell them how you feel be
comfortable in who you are of course and
then people will listen yeah I try to be
really even tempered you know because
people will always be like women are so
emotional or calm down or relaxed are
all these trigger words so I don't want
you to have any read I want you to
clearly listen to what I'm saying and so
I practice having an even temper when
when delivering what I have
to say yeah I try to end up being like
suggestive as opposed to demanding so it
feels like it's a collaborative idea is
to just mine so that no one feels like
usurped in their authority or their eco
so it's kind of like I'm like well what
do you think as opposed to well I think
I kind of make it like something that it
feels like we all come up with together
my oh wait Lisa can't read should we
stop and then let me read it to her or
do you want to just well just let's wing
it yeah no no no no you try okay go
ahead
you got this it's a long winter Wow how
do you balance being boss ladies
especially in an industry that still
predominantly run by men as women there
are suggestions that only we can make
their perspectives that only we have and
so I think even though it's
predominantly run by men learning how to
show how important our voices are how
important our audience is it kind of
it's forcing the industry to be a little
bit more collaborative and a little bit
more cognizant of what we have to say
and I think this tip the scales and you
know the industry is run by men yeah but
I surround myself with a lot of women a
lot on me and that really really held
yeah how do you make sure your voice and
opinions are heard even one you might be
nervous or intimidated to speak up well
of course I have parents
so I usually talk to them first and tell
them how I feel and then they would tell
me how to you know say it in the most
comfortable way possible and just tell
me there's nothing to be afraid of and
at the end of it there really isn't
nothing to be afraid of and you just
gotta be confident in yourself I think
you just have to do it and you have to
be okay with the outcome you know
because sometimes you're afraid because
you don't want to upset someone or you
don't want to make anyone else
uncomfortable and you have to just move
beyond the fear yeah I mean I come
across this all the time and I'm a I
tend to be nervous to speak up sometimes
in public places or I like to just hear
out opinions first
i'ma definitely i'ma pull you this side
person and I might be like okay after
everyone's done talking I'm gonna talk
to the person I need to talk to on the
side what are your skin care routines
I tear up my skin yeah yeah my skin
tears about tips especially ii scratch
harder yeah but mine is like it's called
pseudo Phil
Cetaphil meta mil gentle yes gentle yes
gentle and then I definitely try to
drink a lot of waters and
yeah waters good and then I just do a
nice scrub rinse it off and then my face
is nice and clear so when my dog died I
had a very terrible break out which was
stress and that took about a year name
to literally clear up I guess it
triggered some stuff according to the
doctor I don't know what yeah but in a
normal day I use a cleanser and then I
like a little vitamin C cream mixed with
a little argan oil and then a little eye
cream I do none of those things I need
to I'm taking notes I tend to run really
ashy but you have genetically have good
skin that's I'm lucky yeah heat some I'm
here I'm learning you weren't gonna thin
him I wasn't gonna thank you no thank
you but I'm gonna take all those tips
mm-hmm thank you can set a suit of Phil
yeah and argon oil anything not too
heavy
okay cuz I am heavy-handed so that's
good to know what has been the toughest
challenge you have had to overcome in
the entertainment industry well of
course for me was being a kid and doing
big things you know you're only 14 now
you can't do this you can't do that
because I actually was 10 when I pitched
a little so a lot of people didn't
believe me but of course when I worked
with people who actually did and they
trusted in me and my family it all
worked out really well where we are now
so you know breaking into the industry
is really really hard and sometimes it's
about gonna find a secret entrance or
glitch in the system you know that was
the biggest challenge and then even in
breaking in that doesn't mean you get to
stay in like it's a constant journey to
continue to be able to work and to
continue to challenge yourselves
so that's an ongoing challenge for me
you know I think because I did comedy I
think when I started with scary movie it
because it was the biggest thing people
saw me in one way so for me it was
always and people think I'm a comic that
comedian oh you don't do stand-up oh no
I thought I could have sworn I say
Tiffany oh she's the funny one god I
think what I know cuz I was saying she's
you know is a stand that no I'm sorry
they rest of the question that that
wasn't what the point I was making oh
sorry
so it's I'm sorry this might be my
biggest challenge actually but I think
it was like continuing to diversify so I
never got looked at as just one thing so
that I could have a long career what is
the hardest part about dealing with ISA
right that's not what the question I
can't read well but I read that okay
well the I thought that's what I said
let me hold it back little
center-surround female friendship and
handling conflicts within them what's
the best way to navigate conflict
between friends so that no one gets hurt
and the friendship stays intact this is
a good question and why do you think
that is is it are they in the business
or are they non peers well I have
friends that are in the business and
some that aren't because of course you
need definitely need that balance uh
yeah I think too you have to surround
yourself with people who don't want
drama you know a lot of times you know
you have to be conscious to be like well
what kind of friendships are we creating
and you want to make sure that there's a
safe space and that really has to come
from wanting the best for your friends
and if you don't have that you have to
work on that within yourself but you
can't want the best for your friend and
then not speak that and not live that so
I think you have to you have to really
work on being the kind of friend that
you want to have advice for me I'm like
hmm
and you know there's a tendency when you
when you have a conflict with somebody
to tell the the friend in the middle and
sometimes I beat the front in the middle
and I always encourage them to talk to
each other because that he say she say
things can just blow things out of
proportion so you have to talk to each
other directly and if you need to
mediate that or facilitate that then I
think that's the best practice but don't
get into the business of being like
Regina said this marseilles so I don't
know how you want to deal with it I
would encourage Regina decide to my side
directly mm-hmm well then I'm gonna tell
you what she just said about
[Music]